hi Jojo see hua babysits Northwest Kim
Kardashian drops off north at JoJo's
insane insane house for a day of
activities I mean this house has
everything a claw machine mannequins a
slide everything you imagined okay it's
so rainbow isn't it you're gonna go down
the slide yeah okay but anyway it's cute
because they're kids and North is
apparently just a Jojo see wha super fan
and you can come watch the concert oh my
gosh what do you say they dance they
play hide and seek North climbs all over
a car at one point go go see the dream
room OB oh yeah all right let's go
now we caught wind of this little collab
last month when ETS Casa de Laura spoke
to Joe Joe just before the Kids Choice
Awards roll the evidence did you happen
to invite Kim Kardashian West and
Northwest no those are your new best
friends you know actually my mom was
like you should text him and see if
she's coming to Kids Choice Awards and I
was like why didn't you like Dexter and
tell her to bring Norris I was like so
did you know I I didn't I didn't I did
it um but I I mean I still could there's
still time but I did it well we know you
guys have this lovely little face time
the other day after you should
generously sent North your bows yes oh
did you go what did you guys chat about
you know we actually talked about doing
something fun together with me and North
and Kim but okay a collaboration with
the West crew yeah I'm trying my mind is
trying to like think of imaginably
and now we have the answer North's
started the day off a little shy until
she goes completely ham making homemade
slime
how's your sign oh yeah thank you
what was your favorite part about the
day making a big mess
Kim's like oh my god what this is not
the only mess of North's revealed over
the weekend do you like that Segway on
last night's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians season premiered Kim and
Kanye revealed to their family they're
expecting a fourth child via surrogate
we have an announcement oh my god what
we're having a baby but when the story
started seeping out to the public Kim
had her suspicions about the culprit
Gina I think our informant is hmm North
what do you mean she's she's she a mom
at school texts me and goes Congrats I
heard you're having a baby brother and I
thought what and I know that she goes
yeah North is going around saying she
finally has a baby brother so same old
mother anymore job and I was like no
that's just her dream ha ha ha I'm like
she's the lettuce crop that is crazy
yeah I mean nothing I mean I can't just
kidding nobody killed there in here
sometimes I cannot keep up with the
Kardashians I got to admit but I do
relate to North because I too love a
mess be sure to subscribe to all things
et I'm ash Carlson and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]